RICK BOWNESS, HE'S THE HOME
COACH.OLEMAN.
HE GOES DOWN
THEN HE
>> Daryl: STARS AT NEUTRAL ICE.
WHAT THEHE FRONT.
A OF PLAY.
>> DarINEUP.
SEVENTH NHL GAME.
HE IS SCRAMBLE THE RE-RACK.
AGAIN THIS HASCKLUND.
HE GETS ERASED ON THE HALF WALL.
AND THERE IS A PENALTY COMING
HERE AGAINST THE STARS.
TYLER SEGUIN.
POINT OF FOCUS FOR THE STARS.
THEY WENT 1 FOR 1 ON SUNDAY.
THEY PLAY CATCH.
HEISKANEN COMES FREE.
THE SHOT JUST WIDE.TARS
WILL HOLD I DIGGING, AND
MARKSTROM GETS THE COVER.
THAT
ROUGH SHIFT FOR DALLAS.
HERE'S GAUDREAU FEEDING IT BACK
UP HIGH.
TANEV RIGHT CIRCLE, AND IT'S
KICKED OUT BY OETTINGER.
>> Daryl: SP
JOHN KLINGBERG.
LONGNDERSHOWER
DEFENSEMEN.
THEY GET CAUGHT CHASING BACK A
LITTLE B B
KYLINGTON TURNED GAME. HERE.
>> Daryl:ET FELT LIKE THOSE
TOOK HIM A WHILE TO GEKEEPS S
MULTIPLE TIMES.
THEY THE STEP OF
THE NAFLAMESES TKACHUK.
HIS WRAPAROUND WASN'T
HE IS OUT OF THE R PUCK, IT WAS
>> Daryl: VLADAR'S HAD TO COME
THIS STONE